What's up! It's your boy PewDiePie!
2012 PewDiePie here guys. Apparently
every single game ever decided to come.
out at the same time I'm sorry for the
delay but here we are with life is
cringe before the storm
episode  2. Apparently a ton of YouTubers.
had a lot of difficulties with the first
episode of getting it monetized but not
this guy! Haha!
Remember how I kept screaming across all
the music that's cause I know. I know how the system works so now they added a
music slider let's put that shit shizzle
shizzle damn to 1 while also editing the
settings I don't know why I say editing
changing the settings they also have it
hella high what's the lowest set off not
hella low well there you go
there you go thank you very much game
it's a shame because the music is really
one of the finer things with the show
it's really what personally resonated
with me I think it's a wonderful mix of
storytelling and music I think it's a
great thing I find some few good songs
myself from the first episode sorry all
right here we go what happened last
episode I can't believe we barely
started in them crazy fine lip-syncing
the Rachel is totally a gamer
if one day I'm just really going you
remember that guy that we saw under this
tree that was my dad
you didn't have to burn down a tree
because of it that's kind of fucked up
man come on chill also another a
cringing was that it took me about an
hour and a half to figure out that the
character was indeed not max it was the
blue haired girl I don't know all right
we look like we're maybe have a meeting
with a counselor or principal or
something like that principal miss price
how good of you to join us you're well
I'm so sorry we're late my shift ran
late at the diner and then just sorry is
proceed what we don't here yes'm you to
the Blackwell disciplinary process and
the other is all too familiar with it
Blackwell's code of conduct is built
upon a foundation of mutual respect
meant to foster an environment conducive
to education and enrichment when that
respect violated reality check time
yesterday did actually happen I ditched
school with Rachel amber and then Rachel
really did start that fire and that was
after we actually agreed to run away
from here right are you paying attention
to me Chloe
um what miss price the last time we met
an agreement was brokered do you recall
what that was don't screw up don't get
in trouble again
trouble is merely the byproduct miss
price what's at issue is your attitude
we agreed that you would rededicate
yourself to becoming an exemplary
Blackwell citizen we did in the event
that you were unable or unwilling to do
so we also agreed that it will become
pertinent to reassess your future status
at the academy don't mind canvas you
engaged in the following actions
sterday insubordinate language witnesses
saying you were involved in bullying
Nathan Prescott the hell I was I stood
up for that little weirdo then how do
you explain the desecration of mr.
Prescott's photography project well
clearly she didn't throw it so it was
successful say what you will but isn't
happen in real life get out of here
bully maybe you should be talking to
Drew instead of me you know the guy who
actually did what you're accusing me of
miss damn Ryan situation requires
sensitivity it will be handled
separately and Chloe's situation is less
sensitive yeah yeah that's right
discuss other student situations we are
here to discuss your daughter and her
actions convenient mom you know this is
all bullshit
right I'm beginning to suspect that
myself
yeah boy I'm sorry you feel that way but
your daughter's misbehavior is real and
serious do they know about that burning
down on the tree put digis disciplinary
record miss price we needn't discuss any
of it we needn't know because you
severed your relationship with Blackwell
the minute you left school grounds
without permission
what does that mean it means you forced
my hand this is a consequence of your
actions Chloe I have no choice what did
you do it
what why what what yesterday was only my
idea I was having a bad day I needed to
blow off some steam
well it's true actually took it too far
and also I saw it
I've been down that road she told me
you're better than this but I wouldn't
listen
Wow drama class see Chloe was afraid I'd
get in trouble or hurt so she came with
me but only to keep me safe
I'm just sorry you got caught up in it
Chloe
that you allowed me to drag you down to
my level can you forgive me
for what you didn't do anything your
willingness to stand by me even now is
truly inspiring
Chloe is this true yes it is true I'm
wearing the same shirt as me not true
she really is an amazing actor you think
that was amazing are you kidding me miss
price yeah fine fine yes it was her idea
but it's not like she kidnapped me we
were in it together
miss amber based on what you've just
told me I have grounds to punish you are
you sure what you've told me is the
truth
hahahaha yes this can't be the full
story Rachel and the scare I am an adult
ray what is that just to be clear miss
amber you're sure Chloe price didn't
coerce you or coerce her I'm just trying
to get to the bottom of why someone like
well I think we're clear principal Wells
someone like Rachel but not my daughter
excuse me
do you have a list of students you
assume the worst about enjoy the show
you have no right to treat Chloe this
way this is because she's on financial
aid isn't it let's all just calm down
after everything we she's been through
in the last two years you should be
ashamed of yourself
miss price mrs. price Miss grace I
appreciate your position but I assure
you it is only your daughter's past
behavior that has led us here today
I understand mr. wells there is no doubt
that Chloe's behavior must improve but
given what we've just learned about the
negative influence she was under I hope
you will allow her just one March
miss amber I am as surprised as I am
disappointed in you I understand this
being your first infraction in no way
reduces its severity still we will not
be suspending you at this time however
wandered our trust you will no longer be
my administrative assistant first period
oh my god and you will no longer be
involved in Blackwell's performance of
The Tempest boy what the performance is
tonight for someone so aware of our
school calendar miss price I would
expect fewer absences on your record
Oh bazinga she got bazinga ding at that
show since this is her first infraction
mr. Adler yeah I don't tell you how to
run the District Attorney's Office
please don't tell me how to run my
school oh wow the double zing that is a
reason we have understudies for all
circumstances accidental and deliberate
I'm sure your understudy Victoria chase
yes I'm sure
Victoria Chase will do fine that miss
price Chloe is upset for her friend but
we are both grateful that she is not
going to be unduly blamed for what
happened there is plenty of blame to go
around
Chloe's future at Blackwell will be
discussed next unless you had something
to add first miss price we saw your mom
go along with Rachel yeah that's what
she wants anyway nothing to add
I'm glad right Oh Chloe may not have
been the mastermind of yesterday's
events it was as I prefaced the
proverbial last straw in light of your
many past transgressions I have no
choice
oh she's on you for the rest of the year
oh my god other girls idea she confessed
and she will be punished accordingly but
that does not absolve Chloe of her
responsibility you know what I used to
think Chloe was exaggerating about you
but now I see that she didn't go nearly
far enough mrs. price let me remind you
that Chloe's case for reinstatement
begins now her actions and those of your
own will be weighed carefully when the
time comes do you understand me both of
you yes or yes let's see here I'll go
with yes thank you I mean as much as I
ever do Chloe we understand mr. wells I
will have skip Matthews escort you to
clean out your locker you may wait
outside my office until he arrives that
is all good day mrs. price
mr. and mrs. amber ray don't do anything
man I'm just a teenager and I wanted to
skip school man if we said skip school
there's no way we're getting trouble in
sweida names so easy I know I've never
been sent to their office like this you
bet you bet let's make out and thinker
sorry I didn't get the chance to
introduce myself I'm Joyce mrs. price
I'm rose this is James I'm sorry we had
to meet like this no I'm sorry I'm sure
for you this is an unusual circumstance
we really should be going
nice to meet you a Yid same
badda-bing badda-boom mom i'll see you
in the parking lot
hey Chloe oh wait it's just you and me
hey skip you know I was supposed to have
today off right sorry that my totally
fair and impartial hearing and
convenience tieu man I don't really care
about any of this shit
except my secret stash might as well
grab my emergency joint while I'm here
let's look at that well it's like a
doodle man that's yeah let's look at it
had big plans for adding to this collage
oh well oh my god I would always tag
when I was a kid like everywhere it's
cringe as shit man from the rescue
shelter and I would always put like a
Wayne got run over by a car in Sweden we
have like snus or whatever the story
which is like tobacco you ever really
rescued I don't care about you I'm
trying to make this about me
thank you Chloe I it's tobacco you even
put there and there had they had like a
sticker underneath it and I would put
all of them inside the locker just to
like oh look how much i snooched ran my
graffiti pen you've served me well maybe
chem was the class I hated the least
yeah old girls like chemistry what's up
with that that's a sexist segment Felix
well it's true okay
hey dude bro books are expensive you can
sell them come up
I didn't mean to trash it I was gonna
take in she's gonna tag it in front of
this icky okay okay
I might as well okay look homework I
guess we can trash that that guy looks
so strange to me yes we'll take the
picture of the cat that said this is
important stuff guys we're really doing
it it's Phil I'm immersed there you what
game this would make you clean out a
locker huh how many how many games look
at that drawing if this planet am i
right alright let's trash the geometry
you need a whole book about geometry Wow
Amerika Amerika am i right okay let's
trash then let's trash day this is good
I enjoy personally to throw away stuff
so this feels great
people hold on way too much to
materialistic items okay okay and let's
get the emergency stash of weed which
seems like a terrible idea to keep in a
school but I guess this is hot
jackpot wait what the hell no no don't
fuckin swear damn it Justin oh my god
damn it Justin Chloe hey Oh had to
borrow your sash desperate times you
know I promise I'll get you back next
week
okay all right listen up if you're a
teenager and you know about someone's
secret stash and it's not a secret stash
and it's the fault is on you Chloe
second of all if you take someone's
secret stash you don't leave a note okay
what are you stupid that's right that's
what happened
fuck every inch of this place I wish I
could tag it from floor to ceiling
but with skip watching me bathroom then
I'm out cool okay but try to make it
fast will you
just gotta let out that rage in the
whamon bathroom I'm gonna tank the
shizzle out of that yes
angry alright so angry right now
that's a schism marker Chloe alright if
you're gonna do it real get a thick
market what is that
that's like it kind of oh that's not the
size of your marker you're cheating
she's cheating right here well look at
this this is bullshit mean that's not a
tag that's a drawing what I use silly I
don't care
oh wow that's sick how much ink is in
that pen infinite that's cool no no
don't break it
so cringy I love it
don't tag bathrooms is annoying it's
just like our list yeah you know you
gotta tag something decent at least not
a nice place but like you know just some
asshole is gonna have to clean that up
right it's it's your friend even isn't
it anyway I guess she keeps going
she's a savage she can't be helped
it's third oh my god I thought it was a
peanut for a second I'm leaving Rachel
what not obvious at all who did it oh my
god who did this
oh my god who does the bin she's the
Savage okay she understands what it
means to wear your hat like like
whatever ready to go there okay
yeah well that's terrifying what the
heck is that it's gonna be a Halloween
episode that'd be dope I would I would
appreciate that later skip yeah enjoy
cleaning up the bathroom loser
oh hey like David's here awesome
hold on shift to move faster max would
have loved this shit stupid max I don't
their letter to max Oh care about you
max never send at least Journal max
won't abandon me the way real max - oh
my god let it go who cares Chloe you
can't keep doing this in Treme let's jog
over there has a pothole right there
let's watch out maybe they'll use my
scholarship money to finally fix this
pothole how does pothole exist it's
about damn time David please I'll handle
it Kissimmee Chloe after today yep Chloe
your mother and I have been talking
I don't care I know that's what we need
to talk about this isn't a fight Chloe
it's a conversation remember that a
conversation not with sergeant asshat
here I just need some space oh he looked
like he was sad about it she's my mother
if my mother has something to say she
will say it to me she has the problem is
you don't listen maybe if you try
listening to me instead of fighting me
about everything you might actually
learn a thing or two what how to be a
soldier soldiers put family and future
above self and now getting kicked out of
school that's what losers do David
that's out of line
you weren't with us in there Chloe was
treated unfairly now you're making
excuses for her Chloe needs to take
responsibility I decide what Chloe needs
not you oh right now what I need most of
all is for the two of you to start
getting along Chloe I don't want to
fight I care about your mother very much
and you too I'd like for us to start
over what do you say that was easy
yeah I'm not gonna say no to that reset
button pressed I am glad to hear it from
now on I will be assisting your mother
in a few areas like making sure that you
are no longer abusing drugs or alcohol
oh great David do you really think now
is the right time Joyce please we must
be a united front 10 ha ha ha ha Chloe
I'd like you to empty your pockets and
place all your belongings on the trunk
of the car what the fuck if we are going
to start over we have to know that you
are not abusing drugs
if you're not you should be eager for
the chance to prove it mom you saw how I
was treated in there now you want to
treat me the same way she's lucky you
need more discipline from you I need my
mom I know Chloe and I'm sorry but David
feel Joyce doing feel this is the best
way to start fresh
Chloe's manipulating her mom dude like
she's really horrible to her well I need
space like oh don't you think
no I comply you want to see my shit so
badly hey remember the first season that
had time travel yeah me neither
is that a vape damn oh it's the marker
Oh someone's privacy doing it for no
reason
yeah it's not like I was looking for
drugs literally smug for someone who
just got kicked out of school
Oh David Chloe I'm sorry can you forgive
me see there you go she shouldn't feel
guilty about that yes I forgive you you
were under a terrible influence I just
worry about you but that's no excuse
Joyce you can't start apologizing now
just really encourage her that's enough
out of you David we need to start
treating each other better and that
means all of us we need a new beginning
a new chapter one that will involve the
three of us together well what does that
mean we both agree that the best thing
for everyone at this stage is for me to
move in yes yes that's what I wanted no
fucking way
Chloe after everything that's happened
I've had a loss I need help
exactly we need a firmer hand steering
this ship
talk to me Chloe tell me what you're
feeling you're wearing too much makeup
you're kind of a there I know what
fucked up man but I'm trying you're
trying I get it
I swear I do and I've been making it
harder for you but this is not the
answer it's the only answer I have Chloe
in a million years I never thought you'd
choose David over me as you go guilting
her again I'm sorry I took that for
granted that's not what she's doing
anyone so dramatic it's about the three
of us having a home together
it'll be better than you think Chloe
once everything's running smoothly
you'll see what a stable home can be
like
whoa where did they go they teleported
what is happening you know maybe he'll
let you drive the car
stupid American cars for their flesh get
a Volvo okay oh there is no home not if
he's there my god
Chloe let her go she'll come home
as soon as her tantrum is over she's
gonna go on a drug tantrum she just went
on a marker tantrum
what kind of tantrum are we gonna see
now oh yeah she's gonna meet up with
their raha life's X mean if you wanna
know which way is up when your whole
life has been turned upside down oh my
god it's so cringe
I can't what the fuck how do you know
when you're home laughs it's just like
I'm just like smoking it up dawg
and like my life my life is crazy it's
crazy
it just got the best for bet I just got
expelled my dadís sucks well life is
hard man she doesn't understand how did
she get six his rifle not there because
done with me I can't go home anymore
he's this junkyard all I've got left
she's gonna hit the car not the buck
she's out of control she needs to be
stopped
nah oh no no
that's a nice car isn't it it could have
been hey don't judge my opinion on cars
it was two years ago I guess I guess
this kind of stuff you don't get over
when you're a kid look maybe she can do
it up with our new dad it looks like a
person this thing is a mess but maybe I
can fix it if this beast will ever run
again the first thing it needs is a new
battery
I found one guess I was pretty pissed at
Rachel last night amazing that someone I
just met could have made me this angry
amazing okay so we need to find a
battery but sorry but how do I open that
text again uh maybe I need my daughter
back maybe I just need space maybe I
just need space okay maybe I'll meet my
daughter back damn um Elliot wait which
one is the latest message is they after
temperature one hangout no you know wait
our principal oh it's like an auto okay
that's nice you can get text messages
from a principal you're hella weird you
are seriously will get that revenge
look at him when did she text these
she's a texting pro maybe we can check
the school bus for another battery one
of these again boom I never ride ridden
a school bus in Sweden we don't have
them me what to do ooh don't tell me
what to do girl you best not be telling
me this is exact a new car this thing
looks somewhat new maybe the battery
still works
the police notice Wow
shitty ride drug dealer really thought
crime paid better open it what are you
trying to hide under their hood when are
we gonna see max you got to pop the hood
thing you silly Billy that's right I
call you silly Billy what are you gonna
do by now huh I'm savage just like Chloe
okay you know it okay let's take
doesn't matter here we go the bowl said
sure anything like that any better will
do where did she put it where did she
put the battery huh where does the
battery Chloe where is the batter where
did you put the battery Chloe my god
some things best not to ask
I'm alright did we have the car keys
does she know how to like hotwire a car
this is put that in there
you almost kill yourself
oh yeah a screwdriver that's all you
need baby just jam that in there
um this thing and it's more love than I
can give right now in the meantime maybe
I can spruce it up a bit probably a good
idea to cover over this with something
my Pinot while an escape hatch could be
nice
I should probably cover over this
massive hole I need anything else
I'm pedophile look I can find something
else to fix inside the truck okay maybe
there's another light bulb I can put in
here we're gonna make guys we're gonna
make it so nice this place is gonna be
so nice oh my god this place is gonna be
the best okay let's see what else this
trash heap has to offer we can use the
mannequin head as a light bulb and
there's school buses to school but
you've already said that crazy
okay all right okay light bulb we find
it take you might not work then again I
hardly ever work see Chloe's a very
creative person she has a creative soul
in mind she just like to contribute you
know she just needs the right outlet to
do so okay you put her in front
graveyard people say our trash Chloe she
see future she see art you should cover
that life-endangering floor hole quite
nicely why don't you put it over
yourself then best scene good Chloe
that's right I got more where that come
from
no no no no no what was the last thing
we needed it was the floor it was we
need like a rug or something
why not this thing here still love
opening up the diner with mom before
school
I guess those days are now officially
over
yeah because your dad died boomba zingin
sorry here's a side of Arcadia Bay they
don't put on the postcards oh there we
go
yeah that's not nasty I'll cover that
torn seat and look awesome doing it yeah
that's probably doesn't have some
disease on it let's go we did it every
many okay okay very nice oh very nice
this is very nice
come on let's fix it fixing Felix number
one the seat dunt dunt we're gonna even
get to see her doing it because it's too
much effort to enemy but there you go we
did it wow that looks awesome
looks like Jake Paul's new March that
looks ahead passengers enjoy the smell
of sea salt and junkyard oh yeah let's
get the groovy lighting their skin it
one of those Phillips hue lights oh it's
gonna be Red Dog it's gonna be Red Dog
well aren't you gonna try it I guess not
I've seen the light it's awesome
this game makes me want to be blind
sometimes
that I do it or liking it's like a
rested up shopping cart probably drives
like one too
that's if it ever does Drive which seems
questionable still how sweet would that
be
what is that phone dude it looks like a
cigarette box yeah flip phone oh hey
Frank what's up really what about Oh
like drugs I'm hanging out in the
junkyard north of town okay and Frank
after you hang up are you going to smash
your phone like in the movies
No so can I smash it and I definitely
don't want to smash you wish what I'm
saying here
you didn't even cross your legs
hard-earned smoke break hard-earned
let's turn it on your truck look like an
aquarium on wheels
yeah didn't think so tick okay just it
kkkk baby me big day
I don't know why I'm so harsh
kind of cool that light
it's still burning yeah good job there
buddy
Jebus damn forest fires a crazy man
is it regina spektor sounds like it
you of course can't hear it but you know
that's that's the point
thank you copyright she's falling asleep
great she's gonna have a nightmare we're
gonna play nightmare spectrum come on
here it is I'm calling it oh oh
should I marry shit I slept all day
and you gotta get woken up by here her
friend later when the scariest moment
happened
who's the chromate it's kisame crow man
it's her dead get it am i controlling
this no I'm not definitely not
oh look it's her daddy dad
oh oh um let's look at the fire who
cares about our danger if it burned like
this dick that's more bit day it
happened how you doing there papa dad
what are we doing here
he's the grieving marshmallow to the
crow good tuck good tuck my man let's do
some marshmallows that's too big to do
marshmallows get out of here Chloe you
can't possibly be serious right now no
I'm I will not have you stick that giant
stick through the marshmallow how big
are those mutt you got at least how this
game is truly breaking Gramps that made
no sense
let's get RAL here let's get round come
on
more roasting Emma right there like I
haven't rested enough
good luck buddy
nice to frame right there on the fire in
the background amazing isn't it
I can't look away sure don't pretend
you're not mesmerized to you kind of
have a Chronos is that why see you're so
drawn to it you don't even realize the
danger danger fire blinds us just like
darkness but darkness blinds with
absence with loss what is fire blind
with beauty oh wow oh my god
his eyes are gonna turn why sometimes
there's a greater beauty yet to come
incredible fire is jealous Chloe it
wants all the beauty for itself that's
why you need to be careful look at that
oh it's getting spooky oh he's gonna get
old demonic oh oh wow and then the
friend will wake her up sorry what oh
look at that
hasn't anyone ever told you not to fall
asleep with a lit cigarette you could
start a fire oh that's rich of you to
say I'm alright because you started the
oh I oh I get it
so are you gonna invite me in or what uh
let's be a little flirtatious here okay
not sure I don't know I'm not supposed
to give rides to strangers what if I
promised you free candy hop in oh she
running away for realsies
damn you've been busy
it's nothing just some junk I found
lying around yeah we spent about two
minutes
butoh a freaky red light is she gonna
notice everything this is incredible I
can't believe you found us an escape
vehicle already like for us to run away
oh I guess I wasn't thinking about it
that way are you getting cold feet I
thought you were all bye-bye Arcadia Bay
last night I still am I guess
you guess it's not so easy this truck
doesn't even start and we don't have any
money we can figure all of that out I
have no doubt besides there's no rush
true and no Blackwell holy shit that
Wells meeting I'm so sorry I can't
believe he actually suspended you okay
away I'd say it's like the most
believable yeah happen to anyone after
forever
I'm just so pissed about the play how
could they let Victoria chase jack your
role yeah Victoria Chase is like the
biggest bitch an idiot full of sound and
fury signifying nothing
yeah so whoa totally
so what least Wells has no idea what
really went down with us last night
shit got pretty wild ooh what do you
mean us huh last I checked you're the
one who went I'll puff the manic dragon
on that tree last night what were you
thinking I was angry I didn't expect the
whole stupid part to go whoosh but come
on doesn't accomplish sound way cooler
than accessory after the fact is that
the official Arcadia Bay DA's opinion
accomplice it is I'd be way happier
going to jail than having to live at
home with dictator David he announced
his plan
to move in this morning Oh Chloe that's
awful I'm so sorry it's not that bad we
both could use therapy therapy you start
kick back and tell me what's bothering
you I thought that's what she was doing
oh oh oh oh my god well doc let's start
with that Davin there's this dildo with
a Muslim has been dating my mom and now
he thinks he's moving in with us
how do I stop him hmm
that's a hard one I'm not sure there's
really anything you can do because
you're not an ad all talking to you for
just because you can't stop him doesn't
mean you don't fight back the resistance
begins now aah all right you're going to
need a new nickname to mark your enemy
what have you got step what's the most
Christian step douche thank you
dude that's right stance you shooting
himself where he doesn't belong also
he's a douche poetic may I also suggest
stepladder why stepladder I get it
climbs on your mom every night
oh and pretty soon they'll be stepping
down the aisle what the hell kind of
therapist are you sorry it's called
shock therapy highly controversial oh
look hey yo turn that was actually
somewhat therapeutic thank you it's
always a pleasure delving into the mind
of Chloe price and now it's your turn
tell me all about what it's like being
daughter of Arcadia Bay's most Fame
scumbag it sucks to blunt sorry I do
that sometimes
nah I'm just I don't know
oh yeah no Laney Laney Carl hell yeah
that's what I'm talkin about
can we talk about something else of
course fuck no it's a truck damn it it's
the truck a bit that might mean I have
life skills something I've really tried
to avoid that's right changing battery
is extremely difficult to becoming a car
thief that's pretty badass
do you think there's a point when you've
been acting so much that you don't even
have your own personality anymore you
just whatever you think other people
want you to be I think you have a
personality I wasn't talking about me my
dad doesn't really exist you saw him in
Wales his office
the whole thing is a performance and now
I'm starting to feel like everything in
my life is bullshit but he's still my
dad how can I make sure I don't end up
like him you just need someone around
who likes you for who you are and isn't
afraid to call bullshit when needed well
let me know if you find any candidates
for the job I was clearly talking about
myself but things for the bazinga shit
it's playtime gotta go clean out my
dressing room for Victoria it's not
exactly the role I thought I'd be
playing tonight Oh
oh well hey I was thinking that after
the show maybe we could go do something
just you and me there's something
criminal criminally fun that's good it
sounds too spicy wait you forgot your
bag it's for you
just a little survival kit for your new
life on the lam drive safe Chloe oh my
god what's in the box bag I can't wait
what do you think leave a comment right
now and I'm gonna guess I'm gonna guess
a new outfit anyway it's a new outfit
it's it it's a kit on how to dye your
hair blue hello jug Shack come on they
mess with the feel of you in this one
it's kind of interesting oh yeah this
was her like we found this to check out
Rachel Amber's mystery bag this was we
found this when we were looking for
people how much spare time does this
woman have that looks terrible I'm sorry
let's just check the damn Bank
a bag full of clothes told you ten
points to me what did you guess huh yes
I need those and the hair dye come on
where's the hair dye now they're
probably gonna end it on it they want to
make it a big deal
oh look she's here now her character has
changed I got an achievement
Chloe was here
all right let's smash up the place a bit
very nice as you all know you can
literally just put a nail inside any eye
look there was the one there already
how convenient everyone just keeps nails
in their concrete don't they how yeah
okay okay all right okay
that looks really good there on the tire
I would have gotten more for a wall
thing but you know enough messing around
back then I just checked the damn bag
others more nothing like an abandoned
Shack in the middle of a junkyard to
make a girl feel like exploring a new
wardrobe
look at those edgy clothes
no I'm not filling him nup change do we
actually get to pick the outfit or
what's happening you rush shocked skull
bonus outfits let's try the bonus did I
pay for this hotdog man are you serious
this is DLC
obviously hotdog man wins well done
developers for sneaking that one in
there
all right he's at the junkyard let's go
meet him
you see the drug guy isn't he who are
you that's the woman we saw with
Rachel's dad oh my god weird yo Frank
it's Chloe you don't know the secret
password man is the password drugs right
get in here oh wow okay
okay dude it smells like piss in here
shit looks nice you have a rough night
or something every night's a rough night
I've got a notebook in the back
somewhere go get it for me would you
geez man oh he took off I was like what
happened we'll talk
now I'm fetching things in the road
again that's kind of cool dude I heard
the bad news suspension suck you mean
good news I'm stoked word I'm - I
finally got busted yesterday for
spending like weed and then making me go
to her book group on me that sounds
awesome
you know what I would love to go can I
go
that looks like vomit
well look at this cereal is I don't mind
if I do
don't even fucking think about it
damn damn damn damn man part of a
balanced breakfast
- I really want to see Frank's bedroom I
want the damn note is what I want got it
she's so edgy my yeah
- I really want to see Frank's bedroom
say it say it again same
what the heck is he done to that pillow
oh yeah he has a dog hey there it's okay
oh it's a puppy still pompidou get up
here
oh shit huh Hampi do your little killer
that's adorable
it doesn't become adorable those
Butler's they make it impossible to find
these things
so suspended means you can go back to
school
seems pretty chill dude dude that guy
has a lot of beans for the man who
enjoys searing pain with his drive-thru
order where the heck is the stupid Frank
and his BFF that's that's probably so
this is 2010 huh that's probably why
everything was so cringy anything from
the past is cringing except that see
shirt that you just out of think it is
shit I'm in the red time to find out
what Frank wants to discuss
betting slip
$1,200
out of my league
can we talk to him or yeah this it
have a seat
pompidou huh that's one badass name for
a dog
it's French chap skew okay but he's not
a poodle Frank no he's not but I'm gonna
treat him like one okay so who was that
woman what woman the one I saw coming
out of your RV oh yeah I meant to
introduce you her name is mind your own
fucking business
bitch I want an answer
Rachel would want to know more I bet I
can convince Frank it's harmless to tell
me I've only done this twice and I don't
really understand how furious what's the
big deal
idiot I make money by being discreet
so you're supposed to Oh
no shit Frank you think I don't know
about hiding things from other people
just with it pick out their words come
on Tracy I got to protect my clients
happy customers are the foundation of a
good business
if your customers like you because
you're laid-back that's why I like you
so you should keep building up that easy
going by you know sure I guess so why
you still wind up with this chick come
on Frank this is her Katie obey gossip
is all we have to keep us from hanging
ourselves out of boredom yeah see it's
working
I don't know Frank
talk
and I'll get my mom to make you
something special like it worked
how about that firehouse chili of hers
you got it that sounds good the woman
you saw her name's Sarah
you showed up a few weeks ago causing
all kinds of trouble for all sorts of
people like who it's a little out of
your league okay but what kind of
trouble exactly forget about it Chloe
you shouldn't open my mouth
thanks for telling me she is causing all
kinds of trouble oh right
you hear the mill burned down shit
really crazy
my friend Damon runs the place he lost a
lot of money last night
oh he finds out it was us we're gonna be
in trouble man money from what well he's
always had a few things going on I
helped him out with something don't
drown me in the details Frank lately
he's been doing some stuff I don't like
but I don't seem to have much leverage
with what the heck nested sausage again
anyway
you and I not the dog to discuss is this
about the buck 75 what that money that I
owe you
oh yeah yeah no I don't give a shit
about that wait do you have it huh
don't you have richer clients to bother
I should fucking ohmsett well good
because I need everything I've got
you're a pain in the ass I've got bigger
problems right now open my notebook last
page should be some entries for a kid
named drew you know him
drew north yeah he's holy shit it's a
lot of money
gerunds oxy for Damon apparently
football players eat it like candy
that's smart I guess that cards mass
hazing go Bigfoot's problem is I wanted
ruo's a grant and he's not answer mine
coasts
you know what's going on with them
ah he's an unreliable douchebag no this
is the first time he's done this kids
actually smart anyway here's the job I'm
taking you to Blackwell go to the Drewes
room find the money and I'll meet you to
pick it up can you handle that
yeah what do I get from this exchange
okay worse but what's in it for me yes
Daenerys fill me again so if I do this
then we're good that and I'll do even
better I'll give you a 10% cut of the
money
damn damn dog yeah sure
that could be the money that we escaped
with of cars what's the matter chief
chief um Aunt Lucy got tough I'm not
supposed to be in black well I got
suspended this morning
congratulations still easier for you to
go on campus than for me
if you can't even do this price $100
closer to leaving Arcadia Bay with a bit
of cash and the truck fixed Rachel and I
could really do it
we could leave for good you're right a
hundred bucks that's all you need to run
away
good deal
so we're going back to school to play
D&D son hell yeah
I was awesome can we do that again
please is that fire still going on god
damn
how long does forest fires go on man
didn't think I'd be back this soon well
here goes nothing
back at school yet again they've got
some tents up for dressing rooms what
are you up to I'm here to actually
running an errand for later oh really so
bad come better hurry up and get into
the dorms
oh we've been here there was one of my
favorite puzzles here when the game
actually had puzzles in it let's talk to
her hey Steph whoa hey Cal Nastia
surprised to see me on parole I told you
Wells was out to get you that text was a
rare courtesy by the way I don't
normally get involved in other people's
dumb decisions thanks for trying but
skipping yesterday was totally worth it
skipping with Rachel amber does have an
appeal well yeah so what are you doing
here
I'm just picking up something from
somebody it's for a friend now no one
else at this furious what are you doing
what's all this stuff I'm prepping for
The Tempest show tonight I'm the stage
manager oh right I think I knew that
honestly the show is really good it's
worth seeing I'm sure it is I am worried
about Victoria coming in now and trying
to hog every scene but the cast overall
is fantastic you get to see a totally
different side of everyone especially
the guys oh geez well then I'm the queen
I'm intrigued go on like Hayden so
annoying but when he puts on that crown
he's actually very princely and Nathan
Caliban
there's so much stuff there right Deb
yeah well good luck with all of that
maybe I'll see you later hey I wanted to
ask you something
shoot I've been planning to make a move
on Rachel but not if you two were
together make a move so sorry no no no
no no no no no no for me no divorce in
Rachel's business but if you feel
comfortable telling me you think flirt
together it looks to me like you've got
a thing for her and maybe she has a
thing for you and I wouldn't want to get
in the way I'm I don't know it's it's a
lot confusing confusing I can imagine
you ever want to talk to me Chloe you
know you can right I'll see you later
Steph have fun storming the castle
notice whenever one ever says hey you
could always talk to me you never talk
to those people you always go to someone
else
hey look it's shaggy from scab ado let's
go inside the dorm wait she sleeps here
figures looks like they've become a
master lock picker or swipe someone's
keys okay well let's just ask her I'll
see you at the Tempest great no I'm
expelled you dumb back if only we had
the time-travel thing instead of this
lame telling Pingo if only those kids
like that I sighs what Samuel working on
uh the sprinklers
I know when we need to do we need to fix
the sprinkler right Daniels working on
the sprinklers is some damage here might
get his attention Evan is right there is
that hipster taking a picture of a
sprinkler my god what are you doing here
aren't you some thinking over your
endless list of questionable decisions -
oh why do you care about my questionable
decisions it offends me when
intelligence is wasted oh wow must be a
Rick and Morty fan damn straight
Wow Evan looks really ridiculous Chloe
uh-huh I've learned something about
myself recently something that I think
you might understand I've learned that
if I'm passionate about something it's
probably the right thing to care about
for example I've been trying to get the
students and administration interested
in forest fire prevention that is kind
of an odd topic to focus on yeah it's
not like a giant fire is going on people
are so eager to pass on responsibility
to anyone else so that they can live
comfortable unworried and ultimately
meaningless lives you see what happened
who looks like you were right
go Evan you're a hero of the people oh
my god I'm like I do about different
things I'm sure but you only give a shit
about what you give a shit about I like
that anyway you're not supposed to be
here you should leave
what what cover station was that you
only care about what you care about now
what other people who care about other
things but I like that about you that
you don't care about what what are you
saying
we're gonna break his camera aren't we
huh that's some intellectual shit Samuel
yes Samuel nice work sir nice nice work
Sam you all such a nice white door what
though it feels like it's missing
something cousin in attack you right I
can't tag it with Samuel standing right
there come on slap that ass come on slap
that Hayes
how do I get Samuel out of there look
hey Samuel keeping busy always Chloe
price I didn't think you'd be returning
to these hallowed halls so so my god
it's so creepy no did I
I have the feeling it wasn't the books
are bricks of Blackwell that led you
back uh-huh uh what you're here for
someone a special someone yes what do
you think of Rachel amber Rachel amber
is a dragon made of diamonds ah that's
deep do you just make this shit up on
the flyer do you like write it down
beforehand it looks like he writes sonic
fan fiction all the time because you
like the way it feels or is it merely a
desperate defense against experiencing
true intimacy with others is this this
is neighbor for real well I wouldn't
know what are you talking about I'm
looking for Drew North most look at drew
North and see only the athlete but he is
more than that he is Jesus a great heart
he has with much love there's no he's
staring for fear uh-huh I've always
thought he was kind of Oh in that job
look at that job and to know
is just one thing okay I gotta go
okay I've got to go yeah yeah it's been
real yeah no really to yourself coffee
price oh my god thank god that's over
the versus bleach right there I was so
tempted okay alright okay okay alright
we need to get in somehow huh it's a
puzzle in me
it's a puzzle this is the puzzle area
everyone it's a branch I found a tree
branch I'm standing in concrete oh hey
did it let's graffiti it
they're just too high-risk okay we did
it I would have gone with a classic
penis but you know to each his own
max would have jumped on that
photographer position yes stupid max I
don't care about you max Evan will see
me for sure and he sounds like he's in
the mood got him hey shit I wanted you
to go the other way like as far as
possible the other I see we got it sorry
she's such an asshole and for a fresh
start time for a fresh start
the bird we go it's the word come up get
rid of that bird one small flight for
this bird one giant leap backward for
Chloe price oh my god it's painful
sometimes I'm not gonna lie
Oh leak backward got it so this is not
it okay okay yeah yeah I get it I see it
now hey did I get on flippant spurt
don't flip with the bird further nothing
all right now we skid this direction and
it will fly away fly fly little bird get
it now I thought I had to use therap big
stick oh this is beautiful
you got a hipster gasm right there okay
okay let's break sorry
janitor awesome now I just have to wait
for Samuel to turn on this that works
that's crazy I can't believe it just
broke by itself
we did it guys we're little straight-up
savage savage man so cool man all right
let's take the keys sorry Samuel bazinga
as I like to say time to find Drew's
room like how were you jogging over
there let's unlock him like the present
unlock the door and then return the keys
from straightaway please what are you
doing oh wow oh oh hey skip
how is it going not that it isn't great
to see you and all but what are you
doing here yeah what are you doing here
you just get suspended relax I'm just
visiting a friend I can't I really can't
just let you go in I'm going inside dude
you're just gonna have to let this slide
come on we can do this I can in fact I
think I have to ask you to state your
official business
or else fake Kate Blackwell property I
hate to do this to skip but I've got to
get inside
maybe if I make him really uncomfortable
he'll feel guilty and let me pass such
an asshole
what's my official business
women's business skip as in my uterus I
need to use the restroom glad you asked
women bit come on this you not respect
women no it's my job to ask Chloe
your job is creepy then which makes you
kind of a creeper it's not like that do
you know what wells would do to me if I
didn't you know Patrol
you know Wells doesn't really respect
he's doing well
you're just a rent-a-cop who needs a
haircut
I thought we were friends where is this
coming he's so mean yeah I thought we
were friends too I thought we were
friends too but when the man comes down
on you you come down on me is that it I
smile come up I am really sorry Chloe
come on last one
you just looked at my tits just look the
other way skip we didn't do it in
criminal no we did it need to use the
bathroom I don't know what to do
seriously my uterus is on fire dude
she's doing that jenna Marbles moist my
uterus is on fire I don't want to know
where you go you go skip and play go
utero I don't know what to say I'm so
sorry yeah that's right you better beaut
imagine if your européenne er was on
fire thank God I'm on it I won't tell
Wells do what you have to do okay I
won't tell anyone
legend maybe got a message for how's it
going it's going great thank you let's
go I'm guessing they were talking about
Frank's car which is not good it's gonna
be pretty crazy if he I don't use those
keys don't we need the keys to enter the
room though all right
which which one um Babbitt eben thou
shalt not pass I don't think that's him
break a leg tonight that is really gross
I wonder what maximum thing Nathan
Prescott yep definitely Drew's room
whose room am I looking for exactly
sorry
Eliot Hamptons room wonder what he's up
to right now I don't really have time
was it this one I think so look at all
that football what a nerd oh is that
that D&D guy good jury's not here okay
if I were Drew where would I hide my
money oh man
looks like juice dad is having a hard
time he looks so happy
oh yeah they were brothers okay yeah and
I remember
Mikey's figures playing that game
yesterday was actually fun it was oh
hello hello hello a ladder
holy shit drew a college scholarship no
wonder you're so into football
how come mad people get paid to play
football in America guys drew was this
good at sports I bet he can't wait to
get out of our Frank wasn't lying so
many folks are shit out of luck around
here too bad I lost my release form I
was really looking forward to running
all those that the dinner choices are
steak or steak
that's hilarious for the love of God why
I can't really look and there's the
trunk last place it was me in there oh
oh and we got a snoop around for the
hose four digit code probably on a
computer realize Drew was this good
Frank wasn't so many folks are shit out
of luck around
here no it has some prospect plenty of
possible combinations here I could his
birth date
drew is April 3rd and Michael North his
brother is not Jewish the young one
plenty of possible combinations here
no that wouldn't fly a whole lot of
numbers on here would drew really use
something like this for a lot combo no I
don't think so probably maybe behind
this she looks so happy
hmm holy shit drew a college scholarship
hmm I wonder exactly how important 5:16
is to drill
Durga bad guy huh awesome looks like
Mikey's been staying here with Drew well
it must be their plenteous possible
combinations here
but I don't know it's a four-digit code
okay apparently I am in America you put
the months first how about that doesn't
make any sense but now there you go kind
of did a little drew beat you up - oh
let's get the money doing jackpot
someone's gonna walk in now you know it
okay got the money time - oh wow hey LM
on Chloe what are you doing here
cool story bro haha good meme buddy I
was looking for your brother but he's
not here
so why ro we got to go yesterday wasn't
enough you want to go another round
doesn't matter
Mikey get your stuff let's move what
oh that's the guy she a drug guy who the
hell is that
no one stay in here and don't say
anything little brother whatever you do
don't open the door what in the world is
happening you know what's going on Damon
you shouldn't have come here school is
not the place for this
really Damon please don't come here
fucking money I told you I don't have it
cells are down man nobody wants to get
high right now but look it's preseason
we just started two a days those are
gonna kill it I'll be able to sell all
the oxy you got drew you owe me a grand
where is it I said I don't have it right
now I heard about your dad's job by the
way tough times yeah bet a grand would
mean a lot to him right now
where's my money true oh shit I don't
know what you expect me to do I can't
just make money appear out of thin air
you don't have to hit me man I'm good
where is it please just give me one
you're just going to lie there I thought
football players were supposed to be
tough doesn't sound real at all it
sounds like it's like inside of
canisters I'm Linc
he did say stay with my keys and that's
what I'm gonna do your brother said to
stay inside
it'll be okay Mikey hmm it'll be okay
damn you were one tough kid fuck you
yeah what about this hmm
ah good luck running on that knee now
well I'm done getting my money or maybe
it'll be your little brother
I talked to next season damn that got
real
I got dis old man Oh drew it's okay I'm
okay
little brother Thank You Chloe
oh she's leave thanking us oh that's a
tough one uh here it sounds like you
could use this you took this from my
locker fraud no - I I didn't know I I'm
sorry man
my dad he he needs this money way more
the net asshole does thanks drew good
dag
you've been talking to the hospital shut
up Harry Potter don't tell anyone about
this okay
yeah no no way
what um what are you going to do about
Damon I don't know one day at a time I
hear you
seems like you're down on your luck
there now boy a grand that's no good man
why are you dealing drugs huh don't be
dealing drugs man listen to father Felix
you don't deal drugs unless you need a
grand then you do it you're welcome
infinite vis wisdom wisdom shut up from
me feel her feel her father feel her
that is my name very nice amen
it bothers me how that fire is still
going on is no one doing anything this
is gonna be where the play takes place I
look forward to see it
this is backstitch
this day has been yeah all my stuff and
that's before having to watch Victoria
what's your Rachel's role at least I can
be here for Rachel if I can Rachel she's
still going to partake you got this you
got I can't do this
believe in yourself after the drugs she
drinks drugs with tea legend what are
you two doing here - OH
or did you forget you let this loser
drop out sabotage you
but really I should be thanking you now
I have everything I wanted and you've
got a new friend so I guess we're both
doing great now please leave so I can
get ready for my performance even though
I wish I was the one performing tonight
Victoria I really am happy for you
I hope we bought right Chloe no no no oh
we can actually get Victoria let's try a
high road but not me I know how much she
wants to perform all I need to do is
convince Victoria that it's in her best
interest why not just sort of fun I know
it's kind of a dick move
have you really thought this through
Victoria performing tonight could be the
equivalent of social suicide what are
you talking about you think I'm going to
take advice from a loser like you
don't you know your Shakespeare tis
better to have loved and lost than never
to have gone on stage and made a
complete ass of yourself and ever that
actually worked I wasn't sure about that
one people it's cool high school is war
theater is that part of war where you
get impaled by a spear and you shit your
guts out and then all your friends just
one more come on come on I want to do
this are venerated by what am I saying
I don't have to justify myself to you
justify
do whatever yes but trust me if you go
on stage tonight
we did it you'll be the only one out
there not getting a joke
Chloe you're being a little harsh don't
you think
no she's right yes I am what was I
thinking
oh look at this thing I can't yeah like
this I can't play this part I don't know
the lines I don't understand the stupid
play I don't even like theater you don't
know the lines hello I was cast as
understudy to you what were the chances
I was actually going to be here so I
quit the show can go to hell for all I
care I'm not going down with it
yes did your self price I guess I did I
better get ready that was quick ha ha ha
my dear young artists a misfortune most
unkind has befallen us Juliet is way
late that infernal Inferno is the
culprit closing down the roads and
robbing us of our Ariel would that she
could but manifest on her masters whim
as a true spirit alas devoid of an
understudy the situation is a dire one
indeed I'm afraid we may have to cancel
truly we are a curse at lot even my
prodigiously magic nation cannot
conceive of a worse turn of fate that's
it I will not abide this lack of
professionalism any longer I quit
Victoria Oh
I am protesting the entire Blackwell
arts program it's what our towns were
appreciated but not squandered by subpar
faculty good luck with your train wreck
to shave fates to shame mr. Keaton
perhaps I could fill in for Victoria my
dear your visages as a vessel sent by
the heavens to offer passage to my
stranded soul but I'm afraid without
Ariel all they're still lost
oh my mr. Keaton no no he could step in
for Juliet no fucking chance at least
until the roads cleared the cynic she's
the right fit for Juliet's costume she
isn't old Myka tell me my Jesus is a
mess you ever acted before hell no she's
being modest we play improv games all
the time and she's fantastic at it my
dear what if I told you that the entire
fate of the production rests upon your
slender shoulders I'd say you're super
fucked Chloe please I mean come on Chloe
for rock n for rock when please do it
for her you want her say it ha ha ha ha
I can't believe Rachel's talked me into
this
aren't I supposed to be expelled
how are they texting about this right
now
why don't they just talk to each other
oh my death is mocking me from afar
Moshi no okay I mean I guess we're done
right
I can't leave until I've looked at the
script at least once oh my god
I hope it's not long I can't remember
lions it's so difficult suck at it
seriously have to memorize all of this
it's not too bad
do I actually have to memorize it and
are they gonna ask me later all of this
thanks Rachel
all hail a great master okay okay okay
border King soon have a cabin okay okay
now so okay okay okay okay I got it I
got it I got all of it that's right all
of it no probs easy this will be easy
this will be easy guys this would be a
kick in the pake most strange bountiful
fortune pack mine enemies brought to the
shore here cease more questions
thou art inclined to sleep tis a good
dullness and give it way I know thou
canst not choose come away servants come
shit I'm on haha yeah I'm ready now
get up there approach my Ariel come damn
it no problem I've got this I just
walked to Rachel and save my mom oh this
is so crazy
I even have a mark
all nail great mistress I I come to
answer the best pleasure most generous
spirit hostile performed to point the
tempest sorry about that
Creative Cloud Adobe I boarded the Kings
ship the kingship cabin I flamed
amazement the fire I was good and cracks
supper is roaring the mothers painful
seemed to passage and make his bald
waves
my brave Bierut who was so firm so
constant that this coil would not infect
his wrath not a soul
the Kingston bird in hand was the first
man that leaped from his ship and I have
no idea what this story is about cried
hell is here and all the Devils are here
because I don't think that was right
here
close enough but are they
Ariel safe alright I guess this is what
I'm supposed to walk somewhere
definitely supposed to do something with
this oh okay okay yeah we're closed
okkkk not a hair perished and as thou
badest me I have spun about the aisle in
troops Ariel yes their charge exactly is
performed but there's more work more
lines
is there more toil let me remember thee
what thou hast promised how now what is
Val canst demand
Liberty my Liberty indeed nay this most
of all I will not grant that that's not
her line is it what's going on I never
said how dearly I hold thee my habits
been to keep my soul well draped she's
confessing through the plain royal
spirit companion and friend is acting in
my service not replete with excitement
amusement and delight of course mistress
most truly it is so mr. Keith the way
off script it's magical I pray you wish
you to be free
excitements a mere counterfeit of bliss
these storms and these adventures I
prefer to know thou still cared for my
plainest self I have thee in my grasp I
will not Bend
I will not see the flying forth alone
the envy would be more than I could bear
so come with me is that not in thy pow'r
spirit take my hands most faithful
friend for but a little longer I beseech
continue in thy service to my schemes
and when they are complete I swear to
thee we shall fly beyond this Isle the
corners of the world are mere prologue
I'll seek to make thy happiness so great
that in the name of liberties forgot
what says thou to my most hopeful wish
yes I am most pleased your duty done for
now so go forth hence with haste I've
worked to do that was weird
Thanks I like that now well done an
admirable effort and the ending
absolutely transformative I am humbled
we made him happy no problem what the
hell just happened
good thing they had two costumes real
shake it off come on we'll visit Caliban
my slave tis a villain sir I do not love
to look on he does make our fire fetch
in our wood what ho what ho Caliban
come on as we could do as my mother
brushed thou poisonous slave got by the
devil himself filth as thou art I have
lodged the in my known cell till thou
didst seek to violate the honour of my
child oh he's crying fetch us in fuel
and be quick
so lave hence
fuck you no Prescott
well should this music be in the air or
the earth oh thank god
this play is super intense what is it a
spirit
it carries a brave form but tis a spirit
no wench it eats and sleeps and half
such senses as we have I will resist
such entertainment put thy sword up
traitor do you love me o heaven o earth
bear witness to this sound I beyond all
limit of what else in the world do love
prize honoring his tears run down his
beard like winters drops from eaves of
reeds go release them Ariel my charms
I'll break their senses I'll restore and
they shall be themselves now my charms
are all overthrown and what strength I
have mine own prey release me from my
bands with the help of your good hands
I was cool that was nice nice little
segment they snuck in there wasn't ready
for it
Prescott you were amazing man you really
killed it man honestly the way he said
after you there on stage that was dope
that was cool have you guys ever been in
a play on a IR only remember one time
when I was really really really uh I
played Robin Hood
I played the hunter that was in Robin
Hood what is it called the drawers where
is it called Snow White
you're so dead yeah
hella dead it has a charm to it I do
really enjoy these
oh it's hard what about that lady this
is uh this is a long one man was
shitting himself and that dude owes me
it's just I have the green screen set up
with two lights and it gets really hot
in here you know that's it so I'm saying
not complaining this is fun
I mean look at that shot that's a great
shot my dear but what if I told you that
the entire fate of our production rests
upon your surrender shoulders I've never
had an experience like that on stage
right you know you like seriously I love
nights after a show is it always like
this
Oh totally it's such a high no more
nerves just the adrenaline so
first-timer are you proud of yourself
Marlene I think I'm just happy it's over
the last 12 hours have been freaking
intense freaking super duper thank you
for keeping it christian much shit today
right now it's pretty good it's makeup
town okay the whole show was good maybe
a minute yeah makeup tanner
it was magical scissor tan
but dissolute time I just realized
they're underage I meant have a great
time time hold their hand
well this is extremely awkward without
the music what let's leave for real for
real huh you said you wanted to skip
town and never look back like I said
last night let's do it no I seems like
you're having a good time here though
but that was don't say it was just a
crazy thought you mean it I can tell you
want this yeah but like eventually let's
go now oh my gosh she's crazy didn't we
already agree on stage
we can't just why not what about money I
thought you were a high rolling criminal
now I collected the money Frank wanted
but then I gave it back to Drew instead
it sounded like he needs it more no shit
man I'm not looking forward to what
Frank has to say when he finds out maybe
a grand I could believe they could run
away with but a hundred bucks I've got
more than enough to start us out I
always get birthday money for my dad
or should I say hush money any more
questions
I know our parents have been shitty but
we can't just leave them that doesn't
sound like Chloe price wouldn't it hurt
your mom she doesn't deserve that
right I don't deserve to live in the
middle of my parents mistakes right of
course you don't
okay fine you know I'm fine you
convinced Rama Queen where are we going
you tell me what uniquely twisted
location does Chloe price plus Rachel
amber equal hmm of course that west
coasts are okay open room I'm feeling
like an indefinitely long road trip that
sounds like the greatest idea anyone's
ever thought of you and me driving down
the coast filling up our truck with
hilarious souvenirs and every night
we'll find a different Beach to walk
along and watch the Sun go down and one
day you'll be at a gas station fixing
the brakes and some guy with no shirt on
don't you just feel like everything's
possible okay calm down
oh they're gonna kiss okay or no Rachel
stop oh you don't mean this it's it's
just making me feel like shit but this
life you're describing isn't going to
happen
for fuck's sake I've never been more
serious in my life
Chloe what would it take to convince you
oh I'll pick up tattoo come on how about
come on come on come on come on come on
come on
is that convincing enough yeah that is
so cute
it even started snowing ashes
just imagine that hipster music in the
background in the magical moment holy
shit I really missed the music now I
don't know what to do about it
it's a shame mm-hmm what is this stuff
I think it's a sign I think we should
leave tonight really if you want to I'm
ready let's go Oh what what's the
happiness and then we'll get the hell
out of Arcadia Bay
and that sounds perfect
cute how we run integrally honest loyal
damn those doors man hey what up you
thought you would join him huh laughing
um
okay alright okay okay okay right they
actually modeled the whole house
there must be an important piece then
right I can go through all that effort
how are you pick a better time to leave
you know for moms oh you're home knock
wearing rose
Rachel's home and she brought her new
friend girlfriend thank you very much
our surprise star returns you're just in
time
dinner's almost ready Chloe was it it
was it was but that was before I was
suspended now it's that girl who used to
go here what was her name again
all one word ha ha sorry I didn't mean
to bring up any sore subjects what the
hell yeah why is she so very sore Rachel
my honey you were resplendent tonight
thanks Chloe
so they went anywhere join us for dinner
tonight uh-huh she must I must of course
I made chicken ala King I'm sure you
both acted up quite the appetite yeah no
thanks I'm more of a burger a la king
kind of gal she's funny this one I'm
aware Chloe I know exactly meet each
other at our best this morning but with
you and Rachel becoming such fast
friends I insist you join us for dinner
no I we may be fast friends but I am
fast of course
Chloe would you join us for dinner
please of course great I just need to
wash off then I'll be right down
don't belong in the meantime perhaps you
can help me with the table Chloe
sure thing mrs. amber
okay I'm gonna go pack after dinner we
can make our break you cool down here
totally huh
your parents love me they're good at
coming off that way but don't let your
guard down and Chloe we just need to
make it through dinner try not to say
anything that you know that I would
normally say exactly how did the dad not
name with the Amber's okay so did I say
possibly go wrong huh Rachel really
wasn't over achiever before she met me
go out on it that in the bud I mean we
know something's gonna happen
something serious going on should we
improve the crossword instead of helping
out with the table I'm so bad at
crossword
Salva dit oh my god why would you do
that that is so annoying
alright let's just help with the stupid
dishes bothers me how much of a rebel
ships I step in lots of shiny dishes
though
okay guys I wonder if this would be the
most expensive thing I've ever eaten
half of besides my computer of course so
clean
I bet Rose would kill it with my mom at
the diner hi rose
your husband's cheating on you passed
hey there mrs. Amber Chloe I'm so glad
you're joining us tonight
so you putting me to work or what yes if
you could please take four plates from
the cupboard and set them on the table
ooh what if I can't excuse me you said
if I could never mind you're a riot
Chloe all right Chloe
you've set the table without ruining
someone's marriage or piece of cake it's
off to the table with you
you forgot that cutlery but you know
whatever it's not like you need that to
eat this is gameplay okay this is what I
want from games I want to put plates on
the table and I've said it many times
we're we're close with cuphead but table
placement is what I want to do with my
life
oh I understand why they romantic sizing
this idea of running away all the time
like this whole grass is always greener
kind of shit
it's like grow up dude yes Chloe you're
clearly happy here you just need to stop
being an asshole plates check anything
else
actually could you be a dear and ask mr.
amber what he'd like to drink with
dinner I will be a dear talking the
James as long as I can avoid using the
words cheating and scumbag I should be
fine hiya mr. Amber Chloe what can I do
for you what's your vice mr. amber I'm
sorry your wife wants to know what kind
of drink you're having ah let's say
sherry okay 1 2 3 maybe you can help me
understand something
Oh give it a shot
rose and I we're worried about Rachel
yesterday was so unlike her what do you
suppose is going in besides all my bad
behavior rubbing off on her you mean hmm
another joke no I mean no it seemed like
he went wells were happy to believe that
this morning rachel is her own person
she's responsible for her actions I'd be
lying if I said I didn't have concerns
about your friendship but perhaps you're
exactly who Rachel needs right now is
she navigates the choppy waters of
adolescence no I don't know about that
one
good talk buddy Thanks goddamn no she
were just sitting wait is that what they
want that looks of comfy
sorry I pressed it right us I didn't
think something we see shit oh my god
yes Chloe dinner ready
the boss man would like a sherry thank
you the glasses are in the china cabinet
you can place one at his setting how am
I supposed to get to China kidding
it's the fancy looking cabinet right you
got it
I can't do this anymore
stop just stop - up actually I haven't
seen the pencil looking cabinet so I
actually don't know what she's talking
about
I should stay down here until rachel is
ready thank you I actually went up by
accident but where is the china cabinet
oh there it is
strange interior design damn the embers
our fanciest shit it's the triangle
shape one basic shapes now you're
speaking my language
too bad you threw away the geometry BEC
maybe then you would have known as
Cherie this is this is game play guys
this is what I want this is what I want
very nice
ok ok ok
now why yes Chloe oh my god anything
else else feel like I'm getting good at
this
only one last step as our guest you may
do the honor of lighting the candles the
lighter is in this cool I've got my own
Oh light a candle oh you are gonna
Preparedness thanks I think
yeah light some candles and bless this
joint up a bit my god nothing can stop
Chloe now nothing the amber family and
fire what could possibly go wrong here
we go it's dinner time
this one is long man if you set through
all of this with me a plus man no
comment
are you in Rachel in any of the same
classes slippery nipple not since this
morning oh gosh I'm so sorry no that's
cool
we're not what about that fire yeah
dinner's really good mom
thank you Rachel the way the fire
spreads so fast I've never heard of
anything like it yeah it's scary
after those floods upstate I was
overjoyed we had less rain this year who
knew a spring drought could be even more
dangerous you never know where a deadly
spark will come from it's certainly
troubling the latest report from the
Commissioner's Office suggests arson
arson why would anyone do that any
number of reasons with everything going
on in the world today even a town like
Arcadia Bay is an immune to the ills of
society I cannot imagine how difficult
these last few years have been for you
Chloe now that you and Rachel have
become friends I want you to know that
our home is always open to you always
thanks well said dear it's imperative in
such troubled times as these that we
remember what is most important to us
family families not merely a gift it is
a responsibility as such those we love
must be cared for and never ever taken
for granted
oh yeah that's super true I feel like
it's not my place to confront you've
heard that you know it's not up to me to
do that you can always run away from
whatever is bothering you as long as you
just keep calm an interesting philosophy
Chloe yes indeed not one that I would
endorse however I favor confronting my
problems head-on but to each their own I
suppose oh fucking blow me Oh Rachel oh
crap I'm sorry Rachel
can you come help me find another
stoical Chloe I can't sit here and
listen to this bullshit any Rachel stop
it dad you're a hypocrite okay I know
you lying cheating piece of shit
motherfucker excuse me we saw you
yesterday at the Overlook James kissing
that woman James Rachel honey whatever
you saw or think you saw I know it's
hard but I need you to trust me think we
saw are you trying to Gaslight us
there's no thinking involved we saw you
locking lips with some other woman this
part is she and I used the same drug
dealer that's enough you are not welcome
here or around my daughter any longer I
know exactly what kind of person you are
from the moment I saw you and I let my
wife's compassion get the better of Oh
what kind of person is delinquent a
broken girl from a broken home that's
enough James I will not have you
continue to speak
oh this is gonna be bad not the salad
stop lying stop being a politician for
one fucking minute can't you just be my
dad Rachel that woman you saw that
wasn't my daughter it was a daughter oh
my god Oh God was your mother Oh what oh
my god that's crazy I'm freaking out Oh
what what a cool story bro hey made it
fine come on stop crying
ah hey it's me what are you doing
looking at a plan to see mm-hmm
why don't you look at me naked instead
huh here's my number
you call me baby very nice oh oh oh what
is that play based off I never heard of
it
yeah yeah that's right that's what you
get
why why is that text still there this
real ex she really looks like a man
do they actually run away No
we know that rachel is going to die but
we don't know how it's probably gonna
happen in the next episode oh that's
cute I am actually like this one that
was a good ending
he still kissed the mom though
right it still doesn't really explain
life is strange before the storm Episode
two let's look at our choices let's see
what we picked it's always interesting
to find out I like this one I think it
could be a little tighter you know it
was very long it's two hundred and
thirty minutes and I think it's three
hours if you played probably slower than
I do it's just like it doesn't feel I
feel like there's a lot of dialogue I
think there's a lot of stuff that can be
cut and they don't have to put it in I
don't know if they need to make it
longer to justify the price of the game
but personally I wouldn't have any issue
with it being shorter because it does
feel pretty dragged at some points but
overall it's really good and you feel
satisfied by the end of it so it's it's
interesting it's a shame about the music
because it's kind of kind of what makes
it so good but I hope you guys enjoyed
it anyway and if you sat through all of
this with me that's awesome oh yeah
that's a that's a cool thing I
appreciate that I really do and I hope
you enjoyed hanging out with me for two
hours and 20 minutes or however long
it's been
do I not get to see that okay there we
go you took the blame for Rachel 80%
people did okay you emptied your pockets
62% in you gave Damon the money a lot of
people didn't gave Damon the money huh
that that one seemed kind of obvious to
me because maybe maybe it changed you
know because you had the option to go
out but I'm glad we got the one where we
gave the money to Damon because I think
that was the right choice and you asked
Rachel for a kiss twelve percent was
like uh I just wanted I just want to
tattoo okay or it may be a friendship
bracelet but other than that that was it
thank you guys again so much I hope you
enjoyed I forgot that there's this okay
sorry
oh my god what's gonna happen what's
gonna happen episode 3 hell are empty
let's watch I'll play it of course and
that's it
squad fam